foreign
[Music]
there is no running from the 8 news now
investigators on the trail of a
Henderson city councilman accused of
using Native American tribes to charge
huge fees for payday loans now We
examined those lawsuits in depth last
night here well tonight eight news now
investigator Kyle Payne is digging
deeper into it and explains how to
protect yourself Kyle the two Federal
class action lawsuits against Henderson
city councilman Dan Shaw and his
business Holdings very clearly accuse
the company of hiding behind a Native
American tribe in California to skirt
state law
rent a tribe rent a tribe legal aid of
Southern Nevada consumer protection
Attorney Peter Aldis says using tribes
allows companies to charge desperate
borrowers exorbitant interest rates just
have a couple questions the same thing
Henderson city councilman Dan Shaw and
his Loan Company Green Arrow Solutions
are accused of in two Federal class
action lawsuits so it's just the idea
that
the tribe itself isn't really involved
in the business
they are just allowing use of their name
to a business that's otherwise totally
unrelated so that that business can
claim the sovereign immunity protections
of the tribe the tribe in this case is
the end of Pomo Indians in Lake County
California a few hours from San
Francisco the tribe had no comment on
the lawsuits except to say that one of
them is already settled but that doesn't
answer whether they're involved in these
loans the definition of a predatory loan
a loan that you don't think that the
borrower can afford to repay and you're
still going to make money giving that
loan anyway and the collection practices
are very aggressive very very aggressive
Aldous says these loan companies are
notorious for charging your bank account
even if you don't authorize it racking
up overdraft fees and leaving the
vulnerable borrower broke in part
because instead of charging State
regulated interest rates usually around
12 percent these loans charge up to 750
interest making a 500 payment a 1700
repayment leaving the borrower with very
few options closing your bank account is
the number one way to to stop those
debits
the Silver Lining is these companies
very rarely Sue to collect these debts
that subjects them to state courts which
would not protect them from what they do
under the name of the tribe